alguna vez has hecho un barquito o un
avioncito de papel sabías que cada que
doblas la hoja hay un ángulo diferente
cuando hablamos de ángulos hablamos de
la separación que hay entre dos líneas
que se encuentran en algún punto a esta
separación se le conoce como amplitud
pongamos a prueba nuestras habilidades
manuales haciendo una figura con papel y
vamos a descubrir algunos ángulos
consigue un cuadro de papel recuerda que
los cuatro lados deben de medir lo mismo
puedes pausar el vídeo para ir a
conseguirlo vamos a hacer un marco para
una foto
podría ser un lindo regalo
empecemos ya tenemos nuestra hoja
cuadrada vamos a girar la haciendo que
quede una punta hacia arriba
dobla la por la mitad juntando la punta
de abajo con la de arriba
desdobla la hoja y junta la punta del
lado izquierdo con la del lado derecho
si de sombras la hoja verás que hay
ángulos de 90 grados al centro los
identificas toma las dos puntas de los
dados para llevarlas al centro justo así
y ahora toma las dos puntas de arriba y
de abajo para llevarlas al centro
también aquí se forman triángulos y hay
ángulos de 45 grados muy bien vuelve a
desdoblar la hoja observa que tienes un
cuadrado al centro y 4 triángulos
alrededor de él
1 2 3 y 4
toma la punta de cada triángulo y haz un
doblez hacia la base que coincide con la
orilla del cuadrado
hay triángulos más pequeños y ángulos
por todos lados
toma estos triángulos pequeños y dobla
los hacia el frente ya viste que hay un
cuadrado grande y un cuadrado chico aquí
predominan los ángulos de 90 grados
sigamos doblando
dobla cada punta del cuadrado grande
hacia la esquina del cuadrado chico
viste que se formaron más triángulos con
ángulos de 45 grados
listo ahora tenemos un marco hecho de
papel puedes colorearlo hacer un dibujo
o agregar una foto